- Welcome back, everybody.
(audience cheers)
We've got Arnold Schwarzenegger here
and Paul Shaffer along
with our band, y'all.
Our next guests live on one
of the most famous streets in the world,
where children grow smarter,
stronger, and kinder.
You can join them for season
54 of "Sesame Street."
It premiers November 9th on Max.
Everybody please say hello
to Elmo and Oscar the Grouch!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat rock music)
- Hi everybody!
- Hey,
knock it off with all
the cheering will ya?
Don't you know a Grouch is in the house?
- What's up, Arnold,
(audience cheers)
have you ever met anyone
on "Sesame Street"?
Have you ever met anybody?
- Well, they're good
looking characters, amazing.
(audience laughs)
- [Elmo] You too, Mr. Schwarzenegger.
- So Elmo, I heard
that you have a question
for Arnold, right?
- Yes, Elmo does.
Elmo wanted to know that,
how can Elmo be strong
and healthy just like you?
- Cabbage.
- Well, I mean. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- [Elmo] Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
- Very good, but the
most important thing is,
did you eat well?
- Okay.
- A lot of vegetables, a lot of fruits?
And did you exercise every day?
- Oh, yes, okay.
- And you developed the discipline, okay?
(audience laughs)
- (puffs) Like this?
- You gonna do this right now?
- Very nice, you see?
You did really well.
So you do that every day--
- Every day?
- For half an hour
(audience laughs)
to an hour, okay?
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah!
- Hm?
- Oh, you couldn't be tired already,
come on now.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Elmo's just kidding!
Thank you for the advice,
and congratulations.
Congratulations, Ms. Kelly,
on your new set here, it's wonderful!
- Thank you!
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much!
We love it here.
So wait, I love being in
the same city as y'all now.
I love New York.
Thank you for the welcome party.
This has been really cool!
(audience cheers)
(Elmo laughs)
- Yeah, (laughs) yeah!
- We're in same city.
- It's a good thing
- Yeah, we're in
the same city now.
- That's right, yeah.
We are so excited to have you.
Aren't we, Oscar, excited
to have Kelly here?
- Excited is not the word
I would've used, but, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- But we're really, we're happy
to welcome you to the city.
And you know what?
To say welcome,
everybody at "Sesame
Street" all pitched in
and got you some things.
- [Kelly] Oh, what are they?
- Direct from "Sesame Street."
- Is that what's hiding under here?
Is that what's been hiding?
- Yeah, take a look.
- [Kelly] Okay wait, I'm gonna reveal.
- [Elmo] It's a little gift basket
from all your friends at "Sesame"!
- [Arnold] Wow.
(audience aahs)
- Oh my gosh.
This is so sweet.
Okay, so wait,
we're gonna go to the,
this is really cool!
So I can put this up?
- Now, now, now, now.
Just so you know,
that's not the sign.
(audience laughs)
But it's a sign.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I need to watch more
of your program! (laughs)
No, this is awesome.
So I'm gonna put this up here.
Is that okay?
Can I be a part of
"Sesame Street" with you?
- Of course, anytime.
- Okay, thank you.
Okay, so wait, next we're gonna go
to what an interesting little number, so--
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's from me too.
That's actually for Mr.
Tight Sleeves over here.
I heard you had a new book.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, you know what,
I'm gonna pass this off,
this is for you.
- And that's
actually a bookmark.
- This is nice!
- Yeah.
- [Oscar] Scratch and sniff, too.
- Yuck!
- Scratch and sniff?
- Never lose your place, yep.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Okay, wait, so--
- This smells terrible.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah, really, oh!
- He's like, "You're welcome."
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Wait, who are these?
Whose are these?
What are these?
I like these.
- Wait a minute.
You look like a monster.
- Yeah, okay!
- You look
like a "Sesame Street" monster!
- Not the first time I've been told, yeah.
- [Elmo] No no no!
(audience laughs)
It's a good--
- Let's try those on.
- I want you in to try these on.
Try that on, come on.
You think you're good looking now,
wait a minute.
(audience laughs)
- Ay-yo!
- Exactly!
- Hello!
(audience cheers)
- I'll be back!
- Ready for Halloween.
I like it.
Wait, so I--
- I should have had those
when I did "Terminator."
- I know, no, trust me,
(Elmo laughs)
your glasses were cool in that. (laughs)
All right, so wait, Elmo,
I hear that you have advice
for kids with teddy bears.
So I have two kids.
What's the advice?
- Well,
one of those teddy bears is for you,
and one of them is for Mr. Arnold.
- Oh, okay, which one would you like?
- Oh!
- You can pick.
- This is one thing that--
- I think this one, thank you.
- Okay, okay.
- One of the things we
learn on "Sesame Street,"
that is, if you're
feeling nervous or scared,
you could give a soft toy
that you love a big hug.
- Oh!
- You can put it on your belly and do,
it's called belly buddy breathing.
- Okay.
- So you breathe,
and you do it too Oscar!
Come on Oscar!
(Oscar grumbles)
(audience laughs)
- Okay, everybody breathe in
through your nose, like this. (inhales)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then slowly breathe out
through your mouth.
(Kelly exhales)
(Arnold coughs)
Come on Oscar, do it.
- I don't have a nose.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- That is interesting.
- [Elmo] Well, breathe
through your ears, then!
(Elmo laughs)
- That's very interesting.
- But that's just one of the ways
that we learn how to calm down.
- That's really true. I
do this with my children.
We do breathing exercises.
It does really help,
even for 41 year olds having a rough day.
Well, thank you so much, Elmo.
Thank you, Oscar The Grouch! (claps)
(audience cheers and applauds)
You can see your friends
on "Sesame Street"
anytime on Max, season 54.
It premieres November 9th.
All right, so Elmo, Elmo, Elmo,
did you wanna say something with Arnold?
I heard that you might have something
you wanted say with Arnold?
- Oh, yeah, oh!
You know what, can we do the,
can we cut to commercial together?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- 'Cause Elmo kinda knows--
You're done with the segment,
I hear you, okay.
- Elmo knows TV lingo.
Elmo's done a lot of shows, you know.
So Elmo can cut to a
commercial with Mr. Arnold!
- I like it, okay, you ready, okay.
- Ready!
- Okay, y'all can go.
- We'll be back.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat R&B music)